地域目的は的思考能力を作ることだ。これ
が得意なんだ。本能のトレーニングをすれ
ばいい。体育とスポーツは違う。目的が
違うんですよ。
今回地区得意について伺っていきたいんですけど、そもそもこの
3つってこうどういう言葉なんですかね?
これはもう教育について教育の目的やね。世界中が言ってることじゃない。どこも地特育を目的として教育をするわね。
だから日本もそれ一緒なんだけど、日本の
場合それぞれは地域の到着点目的は何なの
?特意の目的は何なの?体育の目的は何な
の?これ全然知らずに我々も教えてもらっ
てないじゃない。よくうちでよっとる時で
も乗れるようになるとみんな自由に乗りた
いって言い出すんや。好きに乗りたいです
もんで乗ってこうよう。どうしていいか
わからん。どこ行っていいか目的がないん
や。だからあそこ行けって言われたらさと
そっちへ行けるんやけど好きにせえ言われ
たらどうしていいかわからんよなっちゃう
。教育も一緒だよ。地域とはこういう目的
だからそういう目的に会うようにやれと
そういう風に教育戦と目的達成できんよね
。例えばね音楽って何の目的であると思う
?分からんやろ。ここは何の目的なんだ?
数学の目的は何なんだ?そういうことを
全くこれ文部省が分からんのかな?我々も
学校行っとる時に聞いてないし。ただ
教わるままにはいはい言って聞いとった
だけ。あれは間違いじゃないかな。
チーク目的は理的思考能力を作ることだ。
これは人間だけができること。科学的に
ものを考える。正しく考える。これが地域
の目的なんよ。チークが色々ある中で、
例えば論理的思考能力を作るためにやっ
てんのが数学だ。みんな数学でもの考える
んやけどね。昔文化系大学受験の時に理下
数学がなかったじゃない。理下数学がない
のに修催になれた。これおかしいんや。理
系はちゃんと理下数学ができんと成り立た
んから。だから論理的思考能力があるじゃ
ない。で、この文化系が数学免除理下免除
というこれがまずかったんやね。だから
教育でも今の教育科学的に考えないじゃ
ない。目的もなしにやれっていうだけで
生徒はどうしていいか分かるにおろちろし
と[音楽]もっといかんのは偏が目的に
なっちまう。
それだと偏差有利な社会になっとるからね。今みんながものを覚えれえんだ。考える必要ない。人が考えてくれたことを覚えればえ、だからだんだんダメになっていくわね。
[音楽]
教育は文化系がやってるんですか?
教育は文化系がやっとるから行かんのよな。教育学部は文化系だよ。だから行かんのじゃない。数学の先生あるいは大育の先生がこれ偉くなれないじゃない。文化系の先生ばっかりが偉くなるじゃない。
そういうね、考える力のない人が教育に
携わるもんで、考える力のある生徒を
養えるわけやないよね。自分ができんこと
を教えたって[音楽]
ダめだ。
校長の文化系と理下系の違いのはどういう
定義なんですか?え、文化系はね、結果
から違いが分かるんよ。理系というのは
成果を上げてなんぼ[音楽]ないよ。
そんなに偉そうなこと言っとったって結果
出せんやつは理系としてはダメな。文化系
は結果関係ないやろ。たくさんものを知っ
とるとか記憶力がええとかそういうことで
偉くなってるじゃない。力人が作った知識
そんなものしょうがないんじゃない?あれ
はね、あの俺がいつも言う地合一に反する
日本の精神論は地一知ってるということは
行動できるということなんだ。自分が結果
を出せないやを知ってると言ってはいかん
の安間なんか見とったら分かるやろ。喋っ
とるだけで何にもできんもん。この前の
安間マなんかもあれ6回目かな出たのは
最初から連中の言うこと同じことばっかり
や。それは50年前にマスコミが言っとっ
たことを今また言っとるんや。うちを
責めるのにな。お前が進歩しないのって
なってくるよね。そういうことでうちを
やっつけれると思っとるの。奴らの世界で
はそれでやっつけれるんだ。実際にやらん
でええからね。そこがいかんとこでね。
精神はあくまでも事故強一。自分ができる
ことは自分が知っていると言ってもえ、
できんことを知っていると言うな。知らん
の。地とはそういうもの。知識というのは
ね、大体知識の式ごべにこういうやつやな
。音式っていうのはね、ソフトウェアと
いう意味だ。正しいことをやれば正しい
ソフトウェアができるやろ。単なる地、彼
らの知識にもなってないやろ。やってない
んだから。教育なんて携わったことのない
奴らがうちを攻めとるわけ。お前んとこの
教育おかしい。知識のなってないじゃん。
やったことない。文化系の世界だから
いかんのよ。成果を上げなくてもよろしい
。
喋ればええ、知ってればええ。これが
チーク。できなきゃだめだよ。行動に移さ
なきゃだめ。精神とはそういうもんだ。
精神は行動のプログラム地だけあったって知識になってなければものは精神とは言えない。校調のチークのお話でよくマスコミが一緒に出てくることが多いかなと思うんですけど、マスコミとチークの関係について伺ってもいいですか?
あれ偏差ばっかりじゃん。
だからマスコミの人間っていうのは実際に
現場にはいないんだから彼らが今言ってる
問題点大体その悪口を言うのがマスコミの
責任だと思っとるからね。それについて
悪口を言うとか批判するとかいう能力が
あるはずがないじゃない。正しい知識は
持ってないんやから自分でやっ[音楽]て
ないんだけど。それなのにそれを言うから
あいつらおかしいんや。原察修催何にも
やらんでも知っていればそれでいいと思っ
とる。これ我々の世界ではバカって言うん
やけどね。ずっと前や出た時にあなたも
あそこも嫌いでしょって言いやがる。それ
なのにどうして出るんや。[音楽]あいつ
ら出してやるというつもりでおるもんでね
。言ったって俺マスコミ大好き言いたい
こと言えるじゃん。だけどマスコミは
大嫌いじゃん。バカばっかりじゃん。
自分の出来せんこと、知りもせんこと、
知識もないこと。それでもって人を責め
とるじゃん。自分が偉いと思い込んどる。
だからいかんのだ。特にリベラルの人間
っていうのはそう。[音楽]自分が正しい
と思い込んどる。
単なる[音楽]哲学。哲学は科学じゃない
。正しいかどうかは分からん。だから
あんなにたくさん哲学があるわけやろ。
哲学が正しければ哲学1つだけよ。仏教
みたいにな、授況みたいに1つだけになる
はずや。いろんな哲学を作るじゃん。
みんな正しくないようわかるにゃ。それを
特に偏差[音楽]哲学が素晴らしいもんだ
と思い込んどるよ。リベラルも哲学の1つ
やろ。だからその素晴らしいものを
知っとる私は素晴らしいんだと。これが
リベラルの怖さよね。マスコミの中には
理系的な考えの人はいないんですかね。系
の関係は非常に少ないんじゃないかな。
この前の早ぶさみたいなああいうな利か系
的な出来事があるんで飛行機が墜落して
どうのこうのとかちょっと理系的に考えと
いけようなことがあるもんであの理系の
人間も入っとるはずや
ところがね前のほら日光機のジャンボの
事故の時あの時に俺はまだ交知所に入っ
とったと思って暇でな新聞をずっと見て
ジャンボを123便があいつを追ったんや
。そしたら新聞に美が[音楽]吹っつん
じまったと。ダッチロールを起こして山に
落ちちゃったんやね。そういう風に書いて
ある。同時に乗っとる写真を見ると
ちゃんと美いとる。そんなことさえも
わからんっていうのかな。誰かがあの魅欲
がすっ飛んだからこんな事故起きたんだっ
[音楽]ていうことを言ったやつがおっ
たらそれをそのまま事実としてあれし
ちまうだけど自分のとこ
の写真を見ると墜落した時に病気が映っ
とるわけやないか分かるか。これが文化系
や。だからいかんな。検証しない。うちの
記事でもそうやろ。うちのいいとこは1つ
も書かんやろ。あれも悪いこれも悪いと
悪いことは100%悪いように書くじゃん
。
かないな。どうしてうちで治ったんだ。裁判で否定されたからだ。音ないよ。裁判でちゃんと教育的効果があったて言っとるよ。
一心はね。記者点結もの変化の順番。それが全然わからん。自分がやったこともない。理解できないんだね。これがんとかない。論理的にものを考えない。それがチークやろ。
数学以外にチークでこういうことをやるといいっていうものはありますか?今日本がまだああいう偏札修が支配してもまだ持っとるのはどうしてやと思う?問式だ。問式を小さい頃にやっとくと論理的思考能力ができるんだ。だったら学校は取り入れりゃええやろ。幼児教育に。ところが文部省は民間より自分たちが上だと思っとるので。
あんな素晴らしい教育を自分たちの教育の
中に入れようとせんのや。大金を払って雲
の3人のところでやってもらえばええや
ないか。そしたら今の偏裁は減るよ。そう
いう文部省の役人が偏裁だからダメな。
論理的に考えれんか。自分たちは偉いから
自分たちの言うことが正しいと思い込ん
じまうんね。教育全体なんやけどリベラル
でやるな。リベラルを追放ししまえば教育
会から教育は正常化するよ。これもうやっ
た国があるんだ。イギリスやったやろ。
イギリスが車両の国になっちまって
どんどんどんどん国力も低下する。
[音楽]でもダめだという時にイギリス病
って言ったわね。あん時にそれは教育の
結果だという言って教育改革した人がおる
んや。さっちゃんやで。女やぞ。
鉄の女やけどね。彼女のおかげで教育が
正常化してイギリスが持ち直した。今の
日本と一緒やないか。今日本どんどん
どんどん落ちていってイギリス病より
ひどい日本病なっとるよ。教育で治ったや
ん。だけどマスコミは絶対そいつ[音楽]
を言わん。自分たちがリベラルだから。
リベラル教育が間違いだとなったら自分
たちが間違いだということになっちまう
もんね。あいつら全部国だ。自分たちの
メンツを立てるため、設けるために日本が
潰れてもええんだ。ヨーロッパやったら
これ革命をね、民主主義の定義からして
マスコミや文部省のような腐った権力
取り除かんといかんの。その取り除く力が
国民にあるん。これが民主義やろ。権力の
交代性ところが国民がリベラルになっ
ちまった。だから文句言わん。対局を見る
目がなくて目の前ばっかり見とるな。
リベラルの教育の仕方見てみ。子供の今
ばっかりに焦点があっとるやろ。
今かわいそうだとか、今喜ばせようとか
将来どうなるんや。仏教で言うように
楽あればありだ。教育初期の段階でこれ
以上ないというような楽をさせてもらった
もんだ。成人してからダメになっとる
じゃん。誰が作ったんや?リベラルが作っ
たんや。どうしてそんなリベラルがいつ
までものさばっとるんや。教育にマスコミ
がリベラルだからね。朝新聞の罪だ。毎日
新聞の罪だな。読み売りはもっと頑張らん
かい。保守に近いんやけど。三系はよく
わからんのやないかな。あれ3系見てごら
ん。政治欄は保守だ。社会面見てごらん。
あれはリベラルやで。社会面が保守ないと
いかんのだ。
得意得って何な?まず特の定義をしようよ
。自然のものはみんな得なんだ。人間が
肉体と精神に分れとる。肉体も得な。精神
の中で自然のものあるもの。本能だ。これ
が得。それを育てよう。これが得意じゃ
ない。何べも言ってるように正しい
あるいは全。これは本能のことだ。理性は
間違い。簡単な例では自動車事故やね。
自動車事故が起こるから自動車をなくせっ
て誰も[音楽]言わんや。自動車はハート
。運転の仕方がソフト。自動車事故という
悪いことはソフトで起こるんだ。人間に
言ってみよう。人間の精神。本能がハード
。理性はソフトな。本能の使い方だから
悪い悪。これは理性の中にあるんだ。本能
は善なんだから。本能は善だから人間は
ここまで生き延びたんだよ。理性のない時
からずっとま延々と人間は種族保存を続け
て今我々がおるんじゃないだっ[音楽]
たら本能が正しいんだ。それを曲げちまう
のが理性やろ。本能通りの報道すれいいの
に本能を曲げた行動するじゃん。これが悪
な。[音楽]だから得意というのは正しい
もの。本能をしっかりさせよう。精神
[音楽]のうちな精神が大事だから人間は
ある。これが得意なんだ。本能の
トレーニングをすればいい。
どうやってトレーニングするか知ってる?
聞いたことないです。
知っとるわけないじゃん。やってもらってないもん。そういうことやね。これがうちのやってたことなんだ。本能のトレーニングだから正しくなる。本能が正しいんだから完璧な本能を作ればこれは正しい。正しい行動ができる。本能が間違ってたりだったり弱かったりすると大にして間違った行動をさせる。悪い行動をする。飛行なんか見とったらそうやね。長本動弱いもんね。
[音楽]
文部科学省は今どういう得意をされて?
文部科学省なんてそんな風に思ってないもん。リベラル使っとるんだから精神論が間違っとるのに日本みたいに本能と理性に分けるなんてことはできない。当然本能のトレーニングしない。何しろラショナリズム欧米の精神論では本能は悪なんだ。犠牲性が全な逆転しとるよね。前説というあの本能のことだ。本能が善よというのが正前説。
[音楽]
欧米の精神論は本能が悪だと言ってるんだ
からあるいは性悪説その代わり理性が善と
言って逆転させとるんね。だから安らは
本当に悪いことするやろ。公米人っていう
のは世界制服してそこの国の財法をみんな
略奪していっ[音楽]てそれがないと人間
を略奪してきて奴隷にしてあれほど悪い
ことをした連中なんであんな悪いことが
できたの理性が全というねそれがあった
からそれにちょっと宗教も絡んどるんや
けどね説と制約説は生前説の方が絶対的に
正しいんですか?正しいに決まるじゃん。
もしせが悪だったら我々は存在しない。
もう滅び取るよ。我々が今ここに存在する
というのは生前説だから。それで存在し
とる。生前説なんだ[音楽]から。で、
ほんのこれを正しく強くトレーニング
しようよ。元々正しいんだから強くすれば
ええんだ。それには方法がある。うちは
それをやっとる。これはね、授況では公然
の木という公然の木ありがたいことに公然
の木の養い方[音楽]つまり本能の
トレーニングの仕方具体的に書いてあるん
だよ。さらに残念なことには学者のこの
部分の役は間違っとるんだ。授況学者とも
あろうものが当然のキは理解できんだよね
。これは申しでこの中に高村中辺っていう
とこがある。の心動かさざる不動一般的に
はの不動という風に呼ばれとる部分がある
[音楽]それをきっちきっちりだよい加減
に読んだってだめきっちり読むと本能の
トレーニングの仕方が書いてあるんだうち
がやってることはさらに素晴らしいこと
やっとるここに書いてある以上のだから
しっかりね特が善なんだから全精神の善や
ね得意をすると善なる人間が出来上がる。
もう1つ言うとね、強いというのは正しい
。強いと正しいは一致するんだ。ついでに
優しい。これも一致するんだ。強いと
優しいはね。だから女の子は自分の天使を
選ぶ時に優しい人っていうあれは強いを
意味しとるもんね。強い人は全だから自分
の定子としてはいいじゃない。コメント欄
であったんですけど格闘家とかで普段のが
悪い人とかは強いけど正しくないんじゃ
ないかっていう反論がありました。そうだ
よ。
だけど肉体的に強いんであったら精神的に強いわけはないやろ。優しいもあるもんみんなそうだ。精神が強い。
小学校の時とか同徳って科目があったんですけどあれは得意ではないんですか?
はい。あれは得意やけど喋ってできるか?ここに書いてあるよ。申しの中にともかく義の意味は分かるかな?リット人なんていうもんで義が悪いことやと思ってる人が多いけど義というのは正しい行動。これを義と言うんだ。
義を行いて生ずるものにして遅いてこれを
取るものにあらざるなりで正しい行動をし
てるとが強くなるだけだけど遅いてこれを
取る勉強して人がこれは義だよと言った
ものを一緒にああこれ下としたって
強くならないよ
道徳は先生から教わるんでよくない
そうそうそうなものにならないだから偏差
やろあることばっかりするん力を悪用する
ようね
北育で具体的に本
のをトレーニングする方法ってどういうのがあるんですか?
それがないから問題ないんやろ。うちはそれができるだから本当の教育ができるんやね。教えてやらない。
校長の認める得意やってるところって何か他にあったりしますか?
厳しいとこは割と得意やっとるよね。右くできからんというマスコミが言うようなとこ得意くやっとるよね。
視聴者に得意行うヒントみたいなものをいただけないでしょうか?
これはね、うちが苦労して作り上げた方法だ。ただで教えてもらうと思うな。
誰を教えてやるか。だけど来たら実際にやってやるよ。
大人はもう手遅れなんですか?
本能が完成すんのはいつぐらいやろうね。おそらく小学校の低学年ぐらいでどしまいやないかな。その間が今甘い世界にしておるやろ。いじめはいかんの?光ってはいかんの。あれで本弄ができないんやね。
大人になってから得意するためには何か方法ってありますか?
ソフトで補うよりしょうがないじゃん。今まで作り上げてきた本能を正しく出すソフト。
それを作ったら本当の特育にはならんけど
、特育間がのことはできるわな。それが昔
やってた特育じゃない。同徳教育ね。
チークと特育のお話を伺ったので次は体育
についてお願いします。
体育とスポーツは違う。目的が違うんです
よ。それなのに今体育と勝してスポーツ
だけやっとうでしょ。あれは文部省の責任
やね。で、どうしてそんな風になったかと
言うとリベラルがうるさいからしいては
いかん。しかないと体育じゃないよ。
ヨットスクールで投稿拒否を直した。あれ
は何をやったかと言うと体育と得意をやっ
たんです。そうしたらば投稿が治ったと
よう考えてもらわんと。学校がチーク変長
になっちまって、[音楽]それも本当の
チークじゃないでしょ。物を覚えればええ
というわけのわからんカスみたいなチーク
やね。で、それをのOB卒業した人間偏が
偉い人になるもんで、もうますますなっ
ちまうんね。物は覚えたらええんやと。
それがチークなんだということになっ
ちまって。偏修催は大体において体育が
苦手でしょ。実際の行動できない人が多い
から文部省の役人でも体育をロソがにする
わな。体育とは何かを考えようともして
ないよね。
体育の目的は正しい行動をする。これには
どうしたらいいか。つまり正しい行動を
する能力をつけよう。これが体育です。
ですから修行修行に納める主と行の方が2
つあるでしょ。職業の行、もう1つ
[音楽]は行う。行うの方が体育。職業の
業こちらの方がスポーツです。ですから
体育行うという字はで変化という意味なん
ですよ。だから変化の仕方を覚える。自分
の進歩の仕方を覚える。体育をやったらば
何をやってもうまくやれるようになる。
これが体育の目的ですよね。力がかかる
ものであろうと、え、細かいテクニックが
いるものであろうと、え、字を確認しても
何でもうまくやれる。そのために体育を
やる。で、うまくやれるということは
正しい精神を作る。これは一致するから。
スポーツは野球なら野球職業の業これは
具体的な行動を示すからっていうわね。
野球なら野球、バスケならバスケ。そう
いう風にそのもののテクニックを上げる。
がスポーツだから目的は試合に勝つことに
なっちゃう。え、これがスポーツです。
ですからスポーツをやってもスポーツに
なって体育的要素は必ずあるから少しは
体育の結果も出せるんだけど体育だけに的
を絞ったものに比べるとやっぱり結果は
ダメなんですわ。スポーツはね。だから
まず体育をしっかりやらせないとイギリス
のパブリックスクール高校やね。午後
みんな体育だ。それぐらい重要しとる。
イギリスの真似を従がる日本がどうして
そいつを取り入れるのかね。こういうとこ
がおかしいんですわ。だから自分の苦手な
ものは排除しようとする。偏察修催やね。
体育はちゃんとやる。今のあの日本の経済
がダメになる。競争力がダメになる。
これは一生懸命働か、働かないからでしょ。正しく働かない、正しく開発しない、粘りがない。こういうものはみんな体育で作れるんですよね。から体育をおろかにした結果が今日本をダウンさしてる。
[音楽]
スポーツだと具体的に何をやるのか想像できるんですけど、体育っていうのは具体的な話だと何をするんですか?
体育的なスポーツがあるんですよ。例えばヨットなんかそうやね。
うちはウインドサーフィンとヨットを使う
からあれ体育的なスポーツなんですわ。
ともかく頑張らんといかん。下手ばっては
いかん。1つはこう命がけということが
あるでしょ。あの人間水に落ちたら死ぬん
だから落ちないようにせんといか生命力が
いるわね。でその生命力が元になって
たくさんの[音楽]現象を頑張るにしても
ここ1番なんてのがそうやね。ここ1番
頑張れ。今のこう見てごらん。ここ1番が
ダメになるから。ここ頑張りゃ乗り切れる
のにというとこがダメ。あのウィンド
サーフィンなんか始てもひゃっと風を吹い
てきてそこ頑張ればスピードがつくのにと
か言って話しちゃうんやね。粘りがない。
頑張りが効かん
で。そういうその非常に有要な性格を
作り上げる[音楽]
。これが体育ですよ。ある程度命がけに
なるもの。
これスポーツはみんな体育の効果があるんですよね。死ぬ前として頑張るんだから自分で考えてごらそういうスポーツはいっぱいあるから。
ウンドサーフィンとかヨットっていうスポーツがうまくなったとは言えないんですか?
ウィンドサーフィンとかあれもうまくなるよ。もちろんそれはスポーツやからね。繰り返しとればうまくなっちゃう。だけどこの前あれん時で説明したやろ。
ああり方、あれは体育のやり方ない。何を養うんだった?
集中力。
集中力ね。集中力を持ってスポーツをやってごらんうまくできるんや。同じ時間かけてもね。これが体育な。剣玉は
[音楽]
つだって体育をすることができる。で、あいつを普通教えるのはただ繰り返し繰り返しやってそのうちに技術ができてうまくなるというそういう方法を取るじゃない。もったいないんや。
下手くそなうちに集中力の練習ができるんだけど
学校で行ってる体育はもうどれもスポーツよりになってる。
しごいたらいかんって言うんやからね。しごくのは消しからんていうあのバカなリベラルどもが守護のが体育じゃない。そういう時でもくびり果てても頑張るとかそいつを悪いことだと言い出したらもう手にえんよね。
体育の定義って何なんですか?
正しい行動のトレーニングだ。正しい行動はなんつった?だろ?体育をやったら正しくやったら義を行うことになる。義を行うと得意ができるやろ。公然の木を養えるけどさ。
その2つで持ってうちは投稿拒否を直して
体育が足りないとどういう風になってしまうんですか?
ああいう投稿拒否の子供飛行の子供みたいになっちまう頑張れないわがままあの子たちの特徴はわがままだよ。そいつをなんか逆に褒めるような感じのことをやるがね。学校行けんだったら来なくてもいいやと行けるようになったらいいらっしゃいなるわけないじゃん。
許してもらえるんやったらこの野郎来
なかったら卒業させんぞ言ったらもう嫌で
も嫌でもなんとか来るわな。そいつを来
なくても卒業させてあげます言ったら俺は
いかんよね。行きたくない。怖いんやけど
非常に弱いあの子たちでもうなんとも怖く
てしょうがないんだ。我々が喜んで学校
行ったやろ。面白いから。我々が喜んで
いくようなところが怖くていけない。また
おかしいと思わんとね。
嫌なことを集中してやる能力っていうのは体育くれ目につくっていうことです。
うん。嫌なことだからやんでいいっていうのが今のあれじゃん。体育の時間見ておらん。炭の方に子供が大勢座り込んで眺めとるわ。体育嫌だからやらんでええんや。んなことしとったらね。それはわがままになるわさ。強くならんわさ。強くならんとだめ。
特に男はないと校調の体育のお話でよくバランス感覚とかがお話出てくると思うんですけど、これについても伺いたいです。
あれ言ってないかな?暗証教系という言葉があるんだ。安定の案。小は詳しい。今は上悔しい。刑は尊敬の。これも上悔しいよね。暗証教系っていうのはね、授教の小学に出てくるんだ。
[音楽]
で、これの意味が学習は分からんからいか
んのや。これはね、進歩の法則ないで案は
安定。安定すると一生懸命やれるんだ。
一生懸命ってのは正しく強くやな。
ほとんどの場合一生懸命やると進歩する。
だから進歩するためには安定せんといかん
だよ。で、もう1つは進歩しよう意思やね
。
これが出らんといかんね。意思を出すためには教うやうやしいけど自分に対してやうやしいんや。結局自分の能力を正しく知ってる。これがうやうやで。思い上がったらダメなんだ。
[音楽]
暗証教系の安定の部分について伺いたいです。
だから子供は安定戦といかん。
これは肉体的と精神的と両方精神的に不
安定やと進歩しないね。そんなも頑張る
ことなんてできない。だから精神的に安定
しないといけないからもう1つは肉体的に
安定行動だからね。安定して行動せんと
いかで行動すると今度は同的安定がいるん
よね。動いとる時に安定して動いとらんだ
けど。で、これを練習しとこうやないか。
そしたらどんどん進歩するんだから。は
ウンドサーフィンはあんなえいいものない
よ。もうバランスロスポーツやもんでね。
あいつをやっとけば構造面の肉体的な安定
はうまくなる。で、[音楽]ちゃんと
できるようになる。
で、もう1つの精神的な安定は男の仕事な
ん。父親が弱いといざという時に自分は
助けてもらえない。強いやつしか助けれん
からね。だから不安なんだ。人間も動物だ
からね。敵から襲われた時にやばいわけ。
そん時に[音楽]
親がバンとこう正面に立って助けてくれれ
ばそのためには父親が強くなていた。だ
から父親が弱いとま電
あるいは父親が全くいない母子家庭やね。
そういうとこの子供が飛行になったり投稿
教になったりするんや。そいつを親の死刑
が悪いからなんちで言い出すわけやね。
バカと思はそうやない。大体リベラルが
離婚さしとるわけやろ。[音楽]リベラル
という哲学であればこんな離婚した方が
ええということになっちゃうからね。そう
いう風にリベラルがとく悪いことする。
その場を良くするために[音楽]戦術的に
いいだけど戦略的にはまずい。反対のこと
やっとるんだ。だからリベラル教育は
みんなおかしくなっちゃうやろ。